okay everyone's saying right now I'm
saying this right now I'm saying that
there's so much opportunity now as well
as loads of problems so what is the
opportunity
what's this opportunity that everyone's
talking about there's so many open the
rich are gonna get richer the poor are
gonna get poorer okay how how will the
rich get richer right now how one of the
opportunities let me take this one win
is Wednesday Channel I was thinking that
I don't know what I'm gonna do about
women's whims don't have to pause it or
something I'm getting more people
applying for winners Wednesday now in
lockdown
then I've ever had before and guess what
all these people are doing they're
applying for winners Wednesday guess how
they're making money I'm just going to
say I'm going to say the opportunity I'm
gonna say what it is it's this it's deal
sourcing its packaging and selling deals
and you might think how can you package
and sell deals from your house right now
I thought that I tried it I did it I
made some money it was tough but people
are coming to me in their shoes and
they're gonna see this you saw this max
Butler was on my youtube channel on
Wednesday I've got a guy called Joseph
who's on my youtube channel I just
interviewed Joseph he's gonna be on next
Wednesday he's making thousands of
pounds from packaging and selling deals
he just messaged me yesterday I
interviewed him actually a few days ago
he messaged me just yesterday and said
can we read you the interview I said why
he said because since then I've made
thousands and thousands of more pounds
and I've got a better success story I'm
like this is just crazy so why are so
many people or why should so many people
be getting into deal sourcing right now
here's why number one because right now
it's hard to buy okay mortgages are
lending but because of the difficult of
them going around the houses and stuff
right now is hard to get financed right
now it is difficult however if you're a
cash buyer it's really really really
friggin easy if you're a cash buyer it
couldn't be easier so what's happening
is all of the cash buyers right now are
buying below market value or the cash
buyers right now are taking advantage in
a buying the HMOs are buying all the
properties so these cash buyers what do
you think they're doing do you think
that these cash buyers have got time to
go and ring agents and ring up
and so it never happens so what they're
doing is they're paying handsomely right
now to deal sources they're paying
handsomely deal sources and deal sources
are cashing in
now listen deal sourcing very real thing
what it is in or doesn't know it's when
you package and sell a property you find
an investment and you pass it to an
investor so the big a deal sauce you
just need four things the first thing
that you need is you need deals and
they're everywhere the second thing you
need is you need investors and they're
everywhere
the third thing you need is you need to
be compliant you need to have the
correct terms and conditions and
different things like that
very very simple the fourth thing that
you need is you need the knowledge and
the reputation to actually go and do
this to make it happen those are the
four things that you need if you have
the knowledge and you as the ability to
be able to sell the deal you have the
deal you're the investors and you're
compliant instead of the business boom
shacka there's no reason why and there's
a lot of people even listening to this
right now that are working in jobs for
two three four thousand a month and are
actually enjoying lock down saying this
is not too bad I'm reading I'm relaxing
I'm at home with my family isn't it
funny that when we're working we think I
want financial freedom so I can be at
home with the family more and they won't
be forced to be at home with the family
anymore we're like mmm this isn't
necessarily as good as I thought it was
right but there's many people that are
there's many people saying this is
fantastic I don't want to go back to
work and let me tell you something if
you learn the skills of deal packaging
you don't have a package and sell deals
to investors and now has never been a
better time you won't necessarily have
to go back to work it's very very easy
think about this the average dealer
sells for what between two and five
thousand pounds so if you just package
and sell one deal a month what does that
mean that means that you've replaced an
average decent salary so listen I want
to I want to train more people upon this
people so Samuel why do you want to
train more people up on this because are
they going to become your competitors I
don't see anything as competitive I see
it as collaboration and listen
ultimately I teach you how to be a deal
sorcerer what does that mean that means
you're probably going to start bringing
me deals you know so I'm happy for you
to be a deal sorcerer I'm
better trained you up I personally
myself have sold hundreds of property
deals I've made hundreds of thousands of
pounds as a property deal sorcerer all
these people you see teaching property
deal sourcing most of them are my
students I've been doing this for years
so I want you to know I want you to
learn the skills so I'm gonna be running
a webinar the webinar is going to be
completely free it's a free webinar and
I'm gonna go through the A to Z of deal
packaging what to do how to build
investors how to package deals what kind
of deals people are looking for I'm
gonna run a free webinar I'm also going
to be taking some people on and I want
to be coaching some people over the next
few weeks and I'll talk about that a
little bit on the webinar so there's
gonna be a second I'm gonna make it
offer on the webinar but the purpose of
the webinar is I'm going to teach you a
to z exactly what to do I'm gonna give
it my all and hopefully I'll be able to
see you on when it's Wednesday so I'm
gonna leave a link below in this video
with access to the webinar is completely
free get yourself booked on you're gonna
love it
let's make some money let's learn some
new skills and let's make ourselves
financially independent so that we don't
have to rely on the government we don't
have to rely on our employers we don't
have to rely on a job we can just
package and sell deals in this
opportunity and then use that money for
what to live on and to invest ourselves
because when you're a deal sorcerer what
do you think you do with the best deals
you keep them yourself so I'll leave a
link below get yourself booked on right
now there's only so many spaces as well
I might even have to delete this video
last time I did this I had to delete the
video because the website crashed to the
learning so many spaces available on the
webinar before he gets all clunky and
begins to get slow so buck on now
limited spaces link in the description
I'll see you there let's kick some ass
go do right now book on right now